madame alors bien voir ce qu'on m'a dit
vous donniez des courbes dargaud et
comme je vais passer quelques jours à
paris je serais intéressé
eh bien écoutez vous a bien dit qu'il
n'y a pas de problème a l'habitude pour
commencer bon pouvoir un petit peu vos
aptitudes on va prendre une phrase dans
le quotidien
je vais vous la traduire et vous avez
les répètes après mois alors d'accord
voilà par exemple on va prendre je sors
et je prends ma voiture ça se dit
commence en argot alors ça se dit je
t'ai kani et je me barre avec ma caisse
à ça c'était alors vous allez me répète
après noir alors il leur dira oui je
decani et je me bats avec michael j'ai
compris
allez-y jeu des canines et je me barre
avec ma caisse
attention la contraction vous souhaitez
commenter
non non ne me sens pas contracter je
vous parle de la contraction dans la
phrase je vous parle de la confection
des verts m'ont dit pas je decani on dit
je t'ai cani ah oui
de même on ne dit pas je me barre on dit
je me bats un bâton que de teraxion
contrats ou des fondations non deux
contractions alors de trois parties
civiles brise donc j'étais bien saisi
jeu decani et je me bats avec ma caisse
ait ma caisse on dit pas avec on dit
avec ma caisse comment s'est envolée des
saf et ak avec mac os x lion est un
essai je déconne il et je me bats à ma
caisse avec nike
est ma caisse autofocus avec maquettes
attakus a claqué cinq mois cuche est
matée manqué d'agacer le maire
repas les genoux pendant calmons nous
parce que c'est ma caisse bac stt
partait bien la bouche la droite mais
des cahiers le secteur pour les chicots
non non je veux dire ouvrez la bouche
pour moi bien les dents vous n'attendez
pas trop parce que vous n'êtes pas un
coût mais voilà ça va ce projet mieux
section arrêté puisque alors commence
alors pour moi voilà comment qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
c'est pas mal du tout maintenant et je
crois je vous met dans les débutants
comme à l'époque h débute finalement se
promet mal combattant alors ce qui a je
veux même si je reviendrais pas notre
goût d'en ramener quelques petits mots
comme ça chez moi pour me faire un peu
la valise avec mes amis je comprends pas
comment on dit madame donc en argot
pièce parce que moi je veux voir ma
petite voisine à tanger du recours pour
piano
allez me dire mais des pièces encore
mieux tandis que via ce salon temps
d'avaler attentes ou non alors une autre
puis pas comme si je veux dire bon je
vais dans un café au café s'il vous
plaît comme on dit s'il vous plaît merde
un café au caire m erde un togo en mai
et alors je vous remercie d'avoir le
capes et je dis je t'emmerde
bonjour merci ça je te remercie je vous
enverrai temps mais je t'emmerde
oui je t'emmerde jamais posé s'est
toujours à paris
[Musique]